So you have GERD.
-I have GERD -Gastroesophageal
reflux disease.
Me too, GERD boys.
GERD boys in the house.
Where did that come from?
Because I have GERD!
You feel-- you have GERD?
I have GERD.
I took this medication for GERD
and then when I take-
my side effect is can't sneeze.
I thought my forehead was going
to blow up and I was like
(mimics sneezing)
And I would just go
choo choo choo.
Not hing came out.
One day-
One day I forgot
my GERD medicine.
I sneezed at - dude - the shit
that was coming out
of my nose was wild.
-Wow you got nose
constipated. -Absolutely.
Hey what's up, everybody.
Welcome
to Stupid Questions .
I'm Chris Distefano.
Tonight's guest, Matthew
Broussard.
You can follow him on Twitter
@MondayPunday
and he's got an album
out called Pan-dantic
-Pedantic. It's pronounced
"pedantic." -Pedantic.
It's pronounced "pedantic."
-You know what that word means,
Chris? -No.
It means ostentatious
or showing of one's knowledge.
Well don't I feel
like a pandan-dick.
Is that- Can we just do it?
Okay so Matthew Broussard,
follow him @MondayPunday.
I was just with him in Vegas
and I
was trying to have a good time
and he was just
making me guess puns.
Okay so this is a man.
I see Tiger Woods. Tiger Woods
with a dragon.
What's the dragon doing?
The dragon is creeping,
leaning, bending down!
What am I doing?
Uh, creeping around.
He's looking over. Looking
dragons on my shoulder.
Does he-does he want you to see
him?
-No, no he's hiding hiding.
Hiding.-Yeah.
-So Tiger... hide... a tiger in
hiding! -No no no.
I love that you believe that was
the answer.
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon!
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon.
I love you, mom.
Alright, next stupid question:
Using the elliptical machine.
-Yeah that's dumb
-Yeah that's dumb.
That's not real.
What does that simulate?
Looks like a cross country
skiing over moguls.
Yeah, do you do the elliptical?
No. No, no.
-Get on the StairMaster. -But
you exercise a lot?
-Yeah, yeah.
-You're ripped.
I saw you in Vegas. You kept
being like let's go to the pool
and I'm like I don't want to go
to the pool with you.
Do you understand
that? I have fluffy fat nipples.
-And you're just built like a...
-I have back hair.
But you work hard! You do have
back hair.
-You saw it.
-Yeah, yeah.
Upper and lower, now. That's the
secret, people
are like
"you're not really Jewish"
I'm like "you should
check out my back hair
"you'll see where it's all
happening."
That's what I-
that's what I like.
There's always balance
in the world.
You know a handsome guy,
you're ripped,
and then when you turned around
I was like oh there it is
he's got back hair.
-Like a frickin dirty...
-And bacne!
Yeah the bacne was gross. I was
like, yeah!
All right next stupid question.
No. Well... In certain
situations it's great.
Or you look like if I...
Like, if I was able
to like press a button
and make my khakis
into a person it's you.
It's the nicest thing anyone's
ever said to me.
Dude, you're my frickin boy.
What are you-
What are you, though?
I guess like a mozzarella stick
if it could talk or like
I don't know- I guess it is...
You're if a UFC T-shirt was a
person.
Thank you so much
for doing the show.
I'd like to give you
a stupid gift now.
Now, you know, I know
you were a swimmer
and even
if you weren't a swimmer
you are the definition of
STF "swim team face."
So I wanted to give you
a swim cap.
Oh.
I hope- I don't know
if it fits your head or know
if it's one size fits all.
I just figured though
if it's made for swimmers
head you have a swimmers head.
-Dude look at that.
-Boom. Yes. Yes.
Thank you for diving into
Stupid Questions
with Chris Distefano.
This is Matthew Broussard.
Find him on on Twitter
and Instagram @MondayPunday
and he's got his album
Pun-dantic, is that right?
-I can't hear you. -Okay.
I think it's Pun-dantic so...
This like ruined my hair.
It didn't ruin-
How do you take off
that swim cap and your hair
is still perfect?
Wow. I want to punch you
and also kiss you.